fan épique bonjour merci d'être avec
nous ce matin sur air france alors déjà
comment vous accueillez ce verdict du
tribunal de toulon j'ai envie de dire
que déjà le chef de l'état visiblement
tour et deux nuls vu qu'on arrivait sur
une nullité de la procédure et donc
c'est quand même assez étonnant qu'un
chef de l'état porte plainte déjà
contrat particulier mais le fasse aussi
mal avec autant d'irrégularités
c'est à dire qu'il n'avait pas donné de
pouvoir personne qui a déposé plainte en
son nom
ces actions ordinaires est-ce que donc
vous sortez un gagnant aujourd'hui de ce
procès est ce que vous regrettez vous
vos propos est-ce que vous regrettez
cette vidéo vous avez fait cet été alors
pas du tout non je reçois que j'ai déjà
fait vingaard à bulles choisi ces gars
des vues sur tout allusive pas parce que
je peux mais comme acte mais je provoque
le chef de l'état depuis un an est
d'ailleurs le chef de sécurité j'avais
déposé plainte au nom du chef de l'état
ce mandat donc précise que je cherche le
chef de l'état depuis un an que tourne
autour d'élise et je provoque est en
fait justement c'est tout à fait ce que
je souhaitais avoir cédé procès car on
ne rompt pas accès aux médias est donc
l'objectif chez en effet comme le disait
le procureur c'est de faire du buzz mais
c'est parfois des buzz pour faire du
buzz
si pierre du buzz pour pouvoir justement
comment on fait actuellement à ses
sauveurs des médias et de dénoncer
justement que les basterds avec un
charity joue depuis deux ans je n'arrive
pas à obtenir et surtout j'essaie de
faire passer un message
notamment quand on passe au tribunal et
donc c'est de le préciser les gilet
jaune sont en résistance à l'oppression
c'est vraiment le message fondamental je
veux faire passer
nous sommes en résistance à l'oppression
et lorsque nous nous sommes présentés au
tribunal
il faut vraiment argumenté sur le fait
que les actes que nous commettons s'est
saoulé les essentiels c'est là la
conséquence de dinde la politique de
mâcon que le béton aux et donc si nous
sommes nous agissons de la sorte nous
provoquons de la sorte c'est car nous
sommes en résistance et comment il a
qualifié la résistance si ce n'est qu'en
passant devant un procès doit par un
droit pénal pour expliquer
l'argumentaire version crackée
montdidier de la nar
stephen explique vous vous chercher à
provoquer vous étiez cet été autour du
fort de brégançon la résidence d'été du
président de la république vous êtes
souvent autour de de l'elysée vous dites
souvent dans vos vidéos que vous voulez
vous entretenir avec avec le chef de
l'état est ce que justement toutes ses
provocations c'est peut-être pas le
meilleur moyen de ne jamais approcher le
président de la république
alors c'est vrai c'est pas de cette
façon-là qui on arriverait à rentrer en
contact avec lui si ce n'est qu' il m'a
identifier les certitudes des moins
identifiés mais je cherche en fait à
avoir plus par la pression populaire et
est ce qu'il y avait proposé depuis des
années à la fois depuis danon maintenant
le dia qui rencontre un des juges n'a
jamais rencontré et donc de me faire
connaître
et en effet je cherche à capter
l'audience une audience par ce moyen là
avec mes direct de régulier sera sur
marianne et vol qui est mon compte de
secours cette marianne et le voilà qui
lance ces puissances pic car je suis
donc bannis avec quelques jours et m'ont
fait la quatrième bannissement de 30
jours sur les choses assez insignifiante
mais voilà donc j'essaie de capter une
audience le dja reconnaître est ce
qu'elle permet justement hier à ce qui
était longtemps
quarante personnes gilet jaune
déterminer les personnes qui ont compris
justement ma logique sans venir venus me
soutenir au tribunal donc je ne paie pas
la demande les fait officiellement
auprès de demel pour le 1er mars 2019
car je suis déclarant des manifestations
gilet jaune isaac le 14 et 15 des
tranchées soldée par an et avoir défini
le parcours avec le chef d'état major de
la préfecture et le commandant
saguenay le moment de lecture j'ai deux
très beaux parcours en passant devant
l'air là vous parlez de manifestations
justement on a on a vu le retour des gis
les jeunes c'était le 12 septembre
dernier
comment vous organisez 7 cette rentrée
est ce qu'il va y avoir d'autres
manifestations dans les jours à venir
le gtc les études des mairies sur tous
les samedis ce n'est pas depuis deux ans
il ya plus ou moins de monde mais les
tuyaux des manifestations il faut pas
s'arrêter uniquement savoir si à
égaliser ou pas et en parler que quand
j'ai vu de belles choses comme ça donc
il ya des manifestations tous les
samedis d'ailleurs samedi prochain il ya
un point de médicalisation devant les
médias et j'ai ainsi devant vous tous
les jours il ya les cas c'est une
manifestation déclarée qui a lieu depuis
plusieurs années ont été répartis dans
le bar où les surcoûts et donc il passe
devant tous les médias c'est une maison
de la radio départ à 14h30
donc voilà mais savoureuse c'est pour
vous dire j'étais différent des
manifestations de l'année dernière j'ai
déposé un courrier en tant que des 40
des manifestations se répandent en
levant bla blas le groupe la plage en
débat emmanuel macron d'année dernière
j'ai proposé durant face ce débat avec
les petits candidats malheureux à la
présidentielle et donc j'estime avoir
soliste et chef de l'état à plusieurs
reprises ne pas avoir de réponse est
donc c'est pour ça que maintenant je
provoque d'une autre façon en m'appuyant
fait sur la colère populaire en faisant
repérer par les gilet jaune pour agir
merci beaucoup stephen explique d'avoir
été avec nous ce matin sur rtl france je
rappelle que vous êtes gilet jaune merci
beaucoup